well Jay it is June 8th and we are
celebrating something that needs to be
celebrated what are we celebrating today
this is the anniversary the fourth
anniversary of the standard Islamic
narrative holes in the narrative s i n
remember what happened four years ago
well to understand what happened four
years ago you're going to have to go
back to
2016 because in 2016 and we're going to
put the video up right here there is
only one Kuran right and that every
Quran in the world is the same of course
that's what you've been told of course
you have been told a
lie okay so there are two Kuran today
right more than two more than two three
qurans more than three more than three
four qurans there are approximately 26
of the Quran 26 different k
you guys get
this get these carage and read them
we're just showing you oh go ahead start
throwing things out it says they
were two differents
the prophets fought but by the time you
they were
killed a hug give attention don't give
face come come
come you better go we're going to make
it more more difficult for
you a little girl oh maybe about 5'2
came across not one not two not four 26
different BRS I remember remember that
mhm and we went down to speaker corner
and held them up and who is standing
there right there filming us but
Muhammad hijab
now remember what happened after he saw
what we were doing he went outside the
the group and he said all Muslims come
to me huh don't look at what they're
showing you don't listen to what they're
saying I'll explain it to you this is
June of 2016 wait wait wait is this the
same Muhammad aab who' been going around
telling everyone about the perfect Dot
Ford dot letter forl letter preservation
of the Quran guy now why does he have to
say that why is it perfectly preserved
because the Quran says that in chapter
85 chter 85: 21 and 22 but it's not just
that it says it has never changed that's
in chap 10:1 15 18: 27 and why does it
never change because Allah himself
guards it in chapter 15:9 so don't get
upset with Muhammad hijob he has to say
that everybody has said that being a
good Muslim being a good Muslim being a
good Muslim obviously something happened
though in 2016 what he didn't say much
did he he didn't have much to tell them
did he so 4 years later he needed help
didn't he yeah so who where he go to he
went to shake yasira because the the
interesting thing that that happened was
for years you got the the dawa fans they
go to their da guy the da guy tells them
perfect preservation right down to the
letter they believe that a Christian
tells them otherwise they don't listen
to the Christian who are you going to
listen to you're going to listen to a
Christian you're going to listen to your
dawa guy so they listen to the daa guy
and that went back and forth until it
was actually put in their faces and
what's amazing is these same dawa fans
will go back to their dawa guy hey you
said letter for letter do for do
preservation but she actually showed us
the copies what's going on here they
keep going to him and eventually he had
he had to solve the problem why him
specifically because he is the only one
that's got a doctorate from Yale
University on this very subject he
literally wrote the book on the Sciences
1995 he got his doctrate so we're now in
2020 so we're talking about 25 years
later he should know what he's talking
about don't you think and his dad Mazar
Kazi was one was one of the people who
popularized popularized I have dawa
books by Mazar Kazi saying there has
never been one Letter's difference
between any two qurans in the history of
the Quran so he's he was raised Josh
ratti was raised to believe this and he
said it many times in fact we're going
to show you right here a clip of where
he saying it over and over and over
again their Quran is exactly the same
the Quran shall remain uncorrupted
untouched and unchallenged until the day
of judgment so he comes to him hoping
that maybe he can answer you phoned me
up and says Jay you got to watch this
but you didn't know what was going to
happen did you I didn't know what was
going to happen and we were shocked by
what happened what happened next that
was that was that was one of the most
that was one of the greatest moments in
the history of daah apologetics pmics
everything all rolled into one this was
Muhammad hijab trying to he he really
seemed to think that yaser kadi is going
to fix all of this I'm talking to yasara
this is the man he's the expert of the
experts he will explain how somehow
there's just what there's just one Quran
he's going to he's going to make it
clear so what did he do first he he put
out his hand remember he put out his
hand he said listen I'm going to this is
a blank sheet of paper tell me blank mus
which one which is the one that you're
going to put on there which is the one
that's the Eternal crime which is the
one that was revealed to Muhammad which
was the one thatman wrote in 652 tell me
which it is it the is it the is it
thei before he could answer before he
could stop his sentence what did Yari
say said it's not an easy question
that's right which it should be if
there's one Quran perfectly preserved
that should be the easiest question in
the history of humanity and it wasn't
but yeah you saw in that interview Yas
aradi basically begging Muhammad hijab
turn the camera stop it yeah I'll talk
to you afterwards please stop this is
not wise Yi it's not wise they're going
to be hearing this out there they're
going to be hearing all of this and so
and this is when it just by Muhammad
hijab continuing to press him because
hij clearly thought no I need to keep
pushing I need to keep pushing then
he'll explain how all this fits together
and there's only been one Quran and just
didn't work and yasar kadi ends up
before that before that what did he say
first he said remember Al jazar who is
the world Authority on the K he wrote 80
books in the 1500s and he did never came
to any conclusion for the last thousand
years he said muslim Scholars don't know
what to do with this question if they
don't know what to do with this question
what do you think I'm going to have to
do with this question and then he said
interesting thing when he says well this
should be an easy question is this what
happened to you when you were at yel
University did you have a crisis of
Faith he said no no no no not a crisis
of Faith crisis of knowledge and then he
did a very interesting thing he held the
Quran up and he says we have a respect
for this Quran we have a red line Beyond
which we don't go there are certain
questions we don't ask of this book but
at Yale University there are no red
lines the Western the non-muslim
scholars don't have those lines and what
did he say about the Western Scholars he
said they keep you see he said as as
Muslims when we raise a question and
someone gives us an answer we just
accept it and he said the Western
academics they'll keep pushing they'll
keep pushing and then he made this
amazing admission he said and we know
they're right because they're quoting
our sources so he's he's acknowledging
that Muslims are are accepting answers
on why they have all these differences
in the Quran what did he say about
Muhammad he said you in the East you in
the East they're looking at you as if
like the with no clothes oh yeah you got
a real problem in here and then he gave
his classic line what was the classic
line uh the standard narrative has holes
in it okay David what standard narrative
it's interesting because we a lot of us
in in apologetics we started using that
phrase to make fun of the idea of the
perfect preservation as if this as if
we're talking about the perfect
preservation of the Quran he's saying
they they holes in that narrative that's
not he was he was arguing much more
extreme he was talking about whether
Muslim Scholars actually have some sort
of explanation of these different qurans
in terms ofu and kirat and so on and
he's
saying Muslim Scholars accept these
answers but if you listen to the Western
academics and you figure out they're
actually they're actually quoting your
own sources to show that your
explanations don't work standard
narrative has holes in it standard what
narrative Islamic standard Islamic sin
sin sin has holes in it we know that all
the time yeah so these are another hole
that we're going to look at sin the
standard Islamic narrative is full of
holes this was not good enough for
Muhammad toob he got upset he put his
hand out a second time remember when he
put it out fny well 28 minutes later 28
minutes later he put his hand out a last
time he says okay listen I need an
answer which is that Quan you listen
there are 30 now not just four there are
30 which is it and what did yarari say
at the very end finally he had to give
in not not an easy I just not an easy
it's not an easy question listen they're
all the Quran and he says Oh you mean a
little bit of Huffs a little bit of yes
a little bit of Huffs a little bit of w
why don't you put some Kai
inck just mix them around that's the CR
now that's when I started clapping M
because yakti doesn't know what we know
we know that that we have looked at
these because we've had them now for at
least 10 years and we have looked
between them now I'm just going to show
you two right here these are the two
most popular ones this is the Huffs
there is the watch this is memorized by
about 3% of the world's Muslim
population this one here is memorized by
93% of the world's Muslim population
this is the one that's now the standard
for us today why because of what they
did in Cairo 100 years ago what did they
do in Cairo 100 years ago well they
tried to standardize the Quran and I
think they spent 7 years working uh
because of the differences because of
the high school school the high school
students who came and they they were
coming to class and they were supposed
to write standardized tests but every
one of them had 30 different answers so
they went to Muhammad IB Al Hussein
alhad and they asked him to just choose
one he chose this one why do you think
he chose it do you know David why do you
think he chose that one I know it that
the hos version had become popular
because of the Ottoman Empire it's the
Ottoman Empire they were the ones that
had all the manuscripts they were the
ones that were changing all of these
manuscript variants so that they were
standardized to this canonical text
that's why Dan Brewbaker who has found
4,000 of them all of them are now
standardized to this text he had to
choose that text what did they do with
the other 29 uh didn't they like send
them to the bottom of the Nile or
something to a boat bu dump them into
the Nile thinking that would do solve
the problem well they burned them the
first time so why not drown them this
time they had did not consider that
hatun was going to come about another
hundred years later and our good friend
huton TOS just 5'2 she found not one not
two 26 of them by the time we were there
in 2016 she has now found all 30 and
you're saying another seven because in
between 1924 and 1936 they changed it
seven times because they found all kinds
of grammatical mistakes that became the
narrative that became the standard for
all of Egypt by 1985 the even s family
saw how successful it was for Egypt they
made it for they made it the standard
work for the whole world now how many
people who are watching were alive in
1985 if you're raising your hand you are
older than the canonical text feel
pretty old that means the canonical text
is pretty new M that happened on June
8th 2020 what then happened hijab took
his first they started editing it and
taking those parts out then hijab took
his version
down two weeks after this went up all
the comments did you look at the
comments oh it was Muslims saying this
is destroying our faith what are you
doing here I'm leaving Islam hundreds of
Muslims I'm leaving an Islam and my
blood is going to be on your shoulders
they had to shut down those comments
within two week yeah so they shut down
comments then uh one of them edited that
part out of the discussion so he went in
there and that part was out uh then one
of them took it down from his and then
one took it down and not only that
people who reposted or even reposted
portions of it Yas aradi started filing
false copyright strikes like you can use
other people's material by fair use if
you're adding commentary he knew he was
filing bogus copyright strikes just for
quoting any part of that and then of
course he uh do you have this um do you
have this interview yep do I have it
does hatun have it y can all of you get
it we have it we've preserved it we're
going to do this every June 8th because
of what happened on 2020 this is the 4th
anniversary but I want to then now go
back to what happened on November 26 in
June 2020 obviously y cardi was having
great problems because he had to delete
that off his site he could not respond
to that till today he still not been
able to respond to that who did he go
after why did he go after you me and Dan
Brubaker uh cuz he likes us so much yeah
well he does I he called us this word
right here Ultra crepidarian we were
called the ultra crepidarian he called
us a lot more than that I think he
called me an uh repulsive repugnant evil
vile jerk that's right and a lot of
other things but yeah Ultra crepidarian
that was the good one this is the word
do you all know what this means somebody
who knows nothing about what they're
talking about who do you think is the
ultra crepidarian here it looks like y
who knew nothing who would not answer
the question and he said don't turn off
the cameras and talk to me afterwards
we'll do a deep dive remember he said
that we'll do a deep dive but for 25
years he said I've never even ever
talked about this ever since he got his
Doctrine so here's the man who doesn't
know how to answer this question he's
saying the th for a thousand years none
of the scholars can answer and he's
calling us the ultra cidarian yeah and
not the entire um who believed the lie
not Muhammad hijab who thought there was
going to be some great explanation it's
just amazing because we were the ones
who were saying it all along we were the
ones who were right the entire time the
entire and you had PE you had Muslims
who knew about the differences in the
Quran but who were lying about it and
then you had the um and the dawa guys
who didn't know who didn't know about it
they're all ignorant we were right the
entire time and at the end of the day
when they finally admit we were right
the entire time we're the dumb ones and
we're the bad guys you know we have a
little thing to saying when we're little
kids I'm the rubber you're the glue
bounce off me and stick on you it looks
like it's bounced right off us right
back onto y Kar right back onto Muhammad
hij now we're going to do something
right now uh we're going to celebrate
this the fourth anniversary folks
uh we're going to eat a little bit of
our cake we have a little bit of our
[Applause]
cake I'll just
say to
you happy birthday to
you happy
[Applause]
birday happy birth birthday to
you just just just wish just wish yasar
kadi and Muhammad hijab could be here to
celebrate this they are this is going to
be sent to them sent to them this is to
thank you guys thank you for doing our
work for us God bless you